Okay. Welcome everybody to another Zoom call. Today I want to start with just talking about some things that have been happening in the clinic that people have questions about.
And that is answering honest questions about your cancer.
We're talking about you answering honest questions to people that ask you because I know it's a touchy subject when people know that you have a serious diagnosis.
Some people have been through this kind of thing before and they know enough just to offer prayers to you and offer support in the way of being there and being a shoulder for you to sound off on or cry on or talk with or pray with.
And then others in a very, very well-meaning way tend to want to give you advice. So that's what we want to talk about here, especially family members, maybe brothers and sisters or children maybe want to kind of step in and show their love in a way that maybe isn't as welcome or welcoming or comforting as you would like.
So we want to talk a little bit about that. There can be believers dilemma when you're deal with cancer as a as a Christian believer.
I find it I find it odd that you know just this week we had two people say the same thing that they when they told their pastor that they had cancer the first thing that was recommended is that we pray for you.
But then the second thing that was recommended but make sure you get to your doctor and do everything that your doctor tells you to do.
And I find that to be kind and I know I'm not trying to say anything negative about a pastor.
But I find that odd that as believers sometimes we say one thing that we trust God and all things we want to hold on to him and trust him that he's got a plan for my life.
But then that doesn't include something very serious happens.
I'm not saying that we don't use wisdom because we are to use wisdom and God does you is is fulfills hills his will through doctors and ambulances and and you know everybody here on earth.
But we have to be careful that we don't overstep that and think that that God isn't able to heal me the way he wants to heal me.
And we have to be careful that we don't listen to society's norm of what decision how you make your decisions.
So let's say I have a cancer diagnosis. What is what is the really the biblical responsibility when you have a serious diagnosis.
Does it say anything in the Bible once you received now cancer diagnosis head to the doctor immediately it doesn't say that doesn't also say to do nothing.
But there's many passages in scripture that say that there is wisdom in a multitude of counselors. But we have to choose our counselors wisely.
But the first thing throughout all the scripture is we have to take our problems to God when we experience an issue regarding an emotional issue or relationship issue or a health issue.
Our first responsibility is believers is to go to him.
We have to trust that we serve a sovereign God. This is no surprise to him.
And he has allowed this in our life and it could be in an exercise obedience to fight against the enemy with this and to pray against the evil intent of the devil in our life trying to steal kill and destroy exactly what Satan tries to do.
But it may also be a lesson to there's multiple lessons in cancer and at least one of them is for us to grow deeper in our relationship with Jesus Christ so that we in that greater level of dependence we rely on him.
We have to realize that there's going to be opposing forces so even with these couple of patients this week that said that I was a little discouraged and I don't need to take it badly again when a pastor's first comment or one of his first comments is go to the doctor and do everything that he's telling you to do.
I don't think that's why he's biblical counsel it's to go to the Lord and do everything that he tells you to do.
So I do believe that when Jesus said my sheep hear my voice that he's talking about us as believers we need to have a relationship so close that we can really understand when the Holy Spirit is speaking to our heart.
We may not hear an audible voice of go to male clinic but we are going to hear in the stillness of our heart what we should be doing and if we're not hearing that again this is a lesson of growing deeper in our relationship with God so that we can hear his voice and we can know the will of God in our life to the best ability that we can.
So we are all working through that pathway of sanctification so that so that we'll be closer to God but these stumbling blocks like a serious diagnosis or relationship issues or other health concerns or financial concerns are not supposed to be stumbling blocks that keep us immature.
They're supposed to be stumbling blocks that make us stronger and growing in our faith and dependence upon him so that we can be closer to him and hear his calling in our life and what his will for us is so that we can know and have that peace that passes all understanding that we are doing the right thing.
And it isn't this you finally reach this euphoria of maturity in this perfect sanctification that's not going to take place until we get to the other side.
It is a walk and it is a daily walk and we're going to have doubts and we're going to have struggles and we're going to have second guesses in our choices that we make that's normal and it reminds me of John the Baptist.
He experienced the call of God in his life and he was baptizing people in the river and he actually heard through the heavens that God said when Jesus came to be baptized that this is my beloved son in who I am well pleased.
How much more of a confirmation could you get than that and then when John the Baptist months or short time later was sitting in the prison cell going to be beheaded by Herod.
Then asked his disciples go ask Jesus if he is the one it's kind of perplexed in one sense like what the heck John I mean you heard that the heavens open and God say that he was the one and now you're having these second guesses that to me is extremely comforting because here's John who Jesus himself called the most important prophet that ever lived
is having second guesses and doubting his own faith and you could use Peter as an example and many other people as an example throughout scripture of people that you could see their flesh and their frailty though they were mighty men and women of God.
They also had that flesh that they were badly. So don't beat yourself up when you are badly doubts and insecurities and your flesh kind of rises to the surface.
We are never going to reach this perfect level of sanctification until we are in heaven with him in a state of perfection in our new heavenly body.
But we need to use some wisdom in a handling these opposing forces that we're dealing with.
You're going to have people that are going to come up against you loving people that are going to come up against you and question what you're doing and maybe bring doubt into the picture.
And some of that is good because sometimes we need to question what we're doing and maybe we need to tweak some things some of that is not necessarily from God and it's just bringing fear in your life and you need to come back that with prayer and asking God to to protect you from that as well.
So you need to respect other people's views when they come at you and church or in a private setting and tell you that they should do something else but then they need to respect yours and that's where drawing some boundaries can help.
And even saying to people and I've had patients say this to people in their life close family members even children that if you can't respect my choices in life and what I'm going to do.
Please don't share anything with me because that's not helpful right now to me that's not healing to me so please keep your opinions to yourself.
I respect your opinions but that has no place in my life right now so drawing that boundary demanding equal respect is is something that you're going to have to do and maybe have your spouse or a helper or a loved one help you with that.
And though there is wisdom and multitude of counselors there's not wisdom and getting advice from every single person so there's other scriptures that say somewhat opposite advice there and it really is based on you should take advice from those that you ask advice from don't take advice from somebody that you don't respect their their thought process and how they're coming to their piece of advice that they're going to give you.
This is just to help protect you and then another question that a lot of people have is why do people push me to do standard care and I have my opinions that I've shared in the past from that part of it is cultural this is just normal in American culture well if you have a serious disease you go to Mayo clinic or whatever.
Because they're going to take care of you well if you do any little bit of research you realize that they don't have the gold standard of care that they claim to have and there's all sorts of possible negatives not that you would go that route but there's value and taking a second look at that.
But a big reason why I believe that people push you to do standard care is that it absolves them from really any responsibility to help you.
So think about this way I tell my brother that I have cancer stage 4 cancer and the way that he can feel kind of absolved from responsibility to actually aid me in my struggle is to say you just need to get to the oncologist go get down to Mayo and just do everything they say that he can walk away from the conversation feeling pretty puffed up that.
Oh, I told him what to do now if he just does that then he shouldn't be fine and if he isn't well then they did everything they can and I didn't really have to do anything else I didn't have to kind of help him research and help him do you see there help him find the right supplements are.
Regardless of what that person chooses to do I didn't have to aid them i'm kind of absolved from the problem so I did my duty.
So that is a major reason in my opinion why people push other people to do standard care it really doesn't have to do with their belief in standard care.
It has to do with basically absolving them from responsibility to actually help the person now they don't have to do anything because I put them in the hands of the best care givers in the land.
I don't have to do anything that was my duty and it gives them a sense of well be well not that I want to take that person sense of well being away from them but I don't need to hear that from people so.
It's maybe wise to go back to that question of only take advice from those that you ask from and if people are against your choice of care just ask them please I respect your decision thank you i'm making an informed decision and getting advice from many different people.
Just please respect my decision and if they can't respect that most people will but if there's people that can't respect that decision ask them to bow out of your relationship with you and tell you deal with the situation then you can come back into friendship with them again.
So another question that people have how do I tell people what I'm doing how much should I explain how do I answer the skeptics somebody said I met church and they say well how's your cancer going and is it are you all better like the mentality of most people is that cancer is like having a war and if you just go take it off now you don't have the war to anymore.
Well anybody that knows anything knows that that's not true even if you go and have breast cancer and have your breast removed doesn't mean you still don't have breast cancer cells float through your body but that's the mentality of Americans we can just.
Erase it away and it disappears we don't have to worry about it again because everything should be all happy happy happy all the time so understand where they're coming from first of all so we don't get upset at their questions.
And then the second thing is how much should I explain well my advice to people is how much should you explain is based upon your relationship with that individual number one if it's a casual relationship and they say you know Kevin how are you doing with your cancer I really care and I don't have a real in depth relationship with that person i'm not going to answer very much.
i'm going to say i'm doing really well thanks for asking I really appreciate that and I will probably say that even if I'm not doing really well because that's me because really I don't want to get into a conversation with that person and that's okay I learned long time ago that if I don't want to get into a conversation with somebody even if they want to have a conversation with me doesn't mean I have to have a conversation with them.
And that is one thing that helped save my emotions a long time ago.
Secondly, if I have a very good relationship with a person and they see me in church and hey how you're doing with the cancer I may give a little more in depth answer i'm doing pretty good I have good days and bad days.
It's a good day so i'm feeling really good and if they then ask any more questions I may go deeper with that answer but i'm very careful not to give out too much information and then if I have a great relationship with that person and they really want to know what's going on with my cancer I will give them any information they want but they will be the people that ask deeper questions.
So most people that ask superficial questions like how you're doing with your cancer they just want to know how you do it and they're just showing you that they care praise God bless them thank them but when people start offering advice that's when you have to decide whether you're going to draw the light or not.
And when people become skeptics in your care that's when you go back to draw your borders and say you know I really respect your your decision and I really respect what you have to say but right now i'm dealing with this and i'm getting a lot of counsel so I thank you.
So you make sure you draw good borders and boundaries in your life to keep yourself protected you don't want unhealthy relationships that are going to hurt you throughout this otherwise it just brings this.
It brings this rolling down in your mind and it's like you got this little demon on your shoulder pitching you in the in the ear and you use it's not a healthy situation there's sometimes that you have to leave a conversation and say in Jesus name I reject that you don't say that so they don't talk to them in person that probably wouldn't be really good for your relationship but you have to say that in your head.
And I think that people deserve mercy to just forgive them they just they don't understand how to communicate with somebody with a serious condition they're struggling with their self esteem and their relationship with God themselves so you just I just think it's an opportunity for you to pray for that person so.
That's some advice and how to answer some some questions maybe as we when we get to open it up you guys will have.
Some some things to say as well.
Another dilemma that we have as believers is this one if God can heal why didn't he heal me why do you heal my wife why do you heal my husband why do you heal my mother why did they die of cancer and the answer to that is is that yes God can heal God is the only one can heal God is the only one that is sustaining every single cellular function your body right.
Now and the only reason why you're alive listening to this right now is because God is keeping you alive so we tend to slip down that slope to think that we have God has a responsibility to me to give me everything I want whether it's health or money or power or happiness or anything like that and we forget that.
That's not why we're here we're here to bring God glory and we're here to find joy in him in our relationship with him and and work through sanctification meaning.
Be changing me from being a fleshly self centered human being because that's really what this question is is this fleshly self centered question but I have that question too so i'm not.
Pretty judgment on anybody we all have those questions how come I don't get what I want how come I don't get healing I don't get this but but that person got healed from cancer God didn't heal me well let's be honest i'm actually like a two year old so that's not.
In that that's not a mature relationship instead maturity at all so as I'm working towards a mature relationship with my Heavenly Father then my healing of cancer and my desire to heal from cancer actually decreases kind of odd yes I want to be healed from cancer but more than anything I want to look more like Jesus today that I did yesterday.
And most of the time I fail at that one right there I got work to do my work is not trying to harder my work is holding on to him more steadfastly so I said in my book and I said.
100 times that when I can see my cancer patients get to the point of being thankful for their cancer not because they have some.
Sadistic qualities to them but that they see that the what has happened through this walk of struggles of cancer and everything else that they're becoming more and more like Jesus and their their.
Who they are has been changed over time it is is changing over time and they can be actually thankful for this disease because it is molding and shaping them more to the image of Jesus Christ then that's where the victory really is and yeah I still want to live to see my grandkids and I you know for all sorts of reasons but more than anything else I want to grow deeper in love with my say.
Maybe you're on a daily basis and that's where it gets down to where is my really what is my really my fight in this and we have to be careful that we don't get tricked in the thinking that my fight is to win this battle over cancer so I can live another 10 years is that really what we're supposed to be doing yes I got to do the right things and eat the right things and use my right and take the right supplements to to give the best chance I have.
For my body to heal but ultimately my fight is not really against this cancer my fight is to to to find joy and treasure greater in my savior today that I did yesterday and that's enough for me because my flesh tends to get in the way all the time so now we're going to open it up for questions and unmute everybody you are all unmuted so if you have some questions.
If you have comments on what we said or something completely on subject well Dr. Conner's this is share. Hi how are you doing good good Monday night I was standing there with a few other gals and they were having a conversation but one of the girls said all sickness comes from unforgiveness how would you respond to that I didn't
respond at all because I mean I mean she knows my situation well first of all I would I would probably do what you did and not respond at all okay especially when someone knows someone knows that I'm standing there and I have cancer they say all sickness comes for
is basically they're saying problem that you have is you have unforgiveness in your life right to me that's your that's completely disrespectful and the statement itself is completely false all sickness doesn't come from anything yeah well you start saying all comes from this you're already wrong so that was just disrespect
well and unless you feel like you you had a godly responsibility to put that person in their place you're you're in situations like that you know we are called to not enter into foolish arguments but sometimes we are called to to tell the truth to people so I think it was probably wise that you said nothing but
if that person you know caught you in a different situation and wanted your advice on that what I would say to that is that oh I respect that I do think that unforgiveness can cause a lot of problems and I do respect that I would
much more respect the person coming to say if you checked your heart about unforgiveness because that can be a problem right prayed through forgiveness is there anybody in your life that you haven't forgiven if you can really dig down deep in that that's why we give you that one heart condition thing right
I do because sometimes there's you do have unforgiveness from somebody you don't even remember right and that can be a block in your healing process but there's a there's a there's a tactful way to bring that up if you really are doing it and love to someone right
but even with that I believe that you know everything can serve a purpose so I would take that piece of advice home and in your quietness of your heart basically just ask the Holy Spirit Lord is there is that can you show me any wicked way in me is there any unforgiveness in me that I have held on to that I am holding on to that I don't even know about can you just reveal it to me I've done that
and it's not really don't feel I'm harboring any ill will against anyone and I even even redid it again just I'm like well you know let's make sure because that's a that's a part of our daily walk is
right lord if there be any sinful way in me can you reveal that to me I know it's right given it already through the blood of Christ but I still lay it at the foot of the cross and ask for forgiveness again and just trust that he's he's he's just purifying me daily and and I get a sin daily because I still have this flesh that I have to deal right
and so it's not about becoming a perfect person that's impossible and it's not about working really hard and following the law because the purpose of the law is for me to realize there's no freaking way I can keep it
right he's Christ on a daily basis so it is just I would just forgive her and just move on and but if a person came to me and asked me that question I'd say thanks for the advice I have worked through that I will work through it again I don't agree that all disease caused from does that mean everybody who dies has unforgiveness of their heart for cradle on
yeah so it's it doesn't make any sense so that's the same thing is the statements where people say well by his stripes we are healed so everybody is healed it's like well then why does everybody die you know you're taking that out of context so it's it's just their immaturity is used to forgive them and pray for them
okay I have I have another question but I'll let somebody else if they have any questions on this particular thing somebody made a comment and said I guess as I try to become more Christ like it except my cancer as a blessing from the Lord I realize how self-centered and self-focused I really am well praise God for that right
through life as as God is molding me in shaping me to his son the painful part about that whole process is that we realize how disgusting our flesh really is very how far I am from accomplishing that task or God accomplishing that task in me and that's what eternity is for
and so I'm not worried about that so it's just it's going it's bringing coming back to the Lord and stay dependent upon him on a daily basis and that that's really the walk of sanctification is just asking God those questions share just like you did Lord is there be anything you need that I need to forgive did I say something wrong and I look at somebody and not encourage them today
just show me it mold me so I could be better tomorrow and that's that's what our walk is thank you what's your other questions here on sulfate I had gotten information on that and some I don't know if it's sulfate or sulfur I guess it's sulfate in our bodies yeah I know I'm getting my getting a whole bunch of blood work tomorrow the results
and I know that's something that he did check but it was something about having low sulfate or something can so sulfur goes through certain metabolic pathways that our body and it can help us with different things so sulfur-contained foods would be like onions and garlic things like that high sulfur-contained foods deals very good for producing food.
So that's what sulfur does and they go through the CBS pathway if you had your genetics done already the CBS pathway travels down part of it makes
glutathione and then you have to detoxify sulfur groups as well and people with with a lot of CBS defects can actually have way too much sulfur groups and can have reactions to it and we have to put them out of more lower sulfur diet.
So this is another thing of you'll see even practitioners that maybe I don't to say it nice but don't are are maybe putting on it's it's like saying all all disease is caused from unforgiveness yeah can unforgiveness cause disease sure can other emotional blocks other emotional wounds can cause disease can lack of sulfur cause certain issues.
Yes it can what do sulfur groups actually do the biggest thing that sulfur groups do is make glutathione and it can help buy to biotoxins to help kill biotoxins that's why garlic can help kill bacterial infections right but too much sulfur groups if you have defects of that pathway down that down that whole pathway you don't get rid of them very well and they can cause all sorts of problems too.
So you have to know that everything is about balance so most people that are eating good diets don't have deficiencies in sulfur it's people that aren't eating good diets that are that are living off of fast foods and processed foods that aren't getting a lot of sulfur in their diets that they could have issues with low sulfur.
Okay but with genetic with certain genetic defects equal a number of people have issues with too much sulfur and we have to actually put them on a lower sulfur diet that tends to cause issues with with some dopamine and serotonin production and they can end up having some just some emotional balance imbalances from that.
Okay thank you.
Any other questions remember to keep sending email questions please put the zoom question heading on it so I remember to catch it and we'll get this up and we'll see you all real soon.
Thank you Dr Conner.
Thank you.